[Music]  [Applause]  chester bennington swipe to Linda speaks  out during the Lincoln Park and friends  tribute concert at the Hollywood Bowl on  Friday Chester would have loved this he  would have loved seeing us lift each  other up depression  let's make Chester proud too Linda  announced a new mental health initiative  in honor of her late husband who  committed suicide on July 20th  [Applause]  I think you're a part of the only reason  that we are able to stand up there and  do this members of Lincoln Park were  joined by friends like blink-182 Alanis  Morissette Gavin Rossdale and more in a  powerful three hour long tribute concert  that streamed to fans around the world  Oh